the U.S pentagon or national security is
built on secret Intelligence on
adversaries and allies
this leak of sensitive documents
published on social media covers both
as the U.S defense secretary met
Ukraine's prime minister at the Pentagon
questions went unanswered secretary
this can't have been their easiest
meeting
[Music]
because the league documents detail U.S
training and Equipment schedules to
support Ukraine in its war with Russia
there was Intelligence on Ukraine's
President Vladimir zielinsky and talk of
Ukraine's battle for the donbash region
likely heading for a stalemate
throughout 2023
another document revealed conversations
between South Korean officials about
their reluctance around a U.S request
for ammunition to be sent to Ukraine
there's a lot of ability to digitally
track back Bradley Morse is a National
Security lawyer based in Washington the
Pentagon investigation into who leaked
what is something he's seen before if
they can figure out the original Source
documents they can then you know sort of
work backwards to track who had access
to it and who were some of the last
people to try to extract that
off-classified servers
following the league the Pentagon spoke
of a very serious risk to National
Security but it's also urged caution
with regard to the documents stating
that slides appear to have been doctored
similarly the UK's Ministry of Defense
says the documents shouldn't be taken at
face value
Ukraine is the French Minister said the
weak documents contained what he called
truths and not truths
I call it a special informational
psychological operation done on purpose
the beneficiary of this operation is of
course Russia the purpose of this
operation is to lower the level of trust
between partners the United States of
America first of all and other countries
whatever its impact on trust between the
United States and its allies the
Pentagon leak can't improve confidence